Every camp, every clinic around America I go and talk to kids,
they don't ask, like, "Man, how did it feel to play 19 years?
How did it feel to play with Dirk or win a—"
- Win a championship, yeah. What question they ask?
- How did it feel for LeBron to dunk on you like that?
- [Laughing]
- Like, c’mon man. Get outta here.
♪♪♪
- New year, new season of Untold Stories,
and we're listening to what the fans want.
We started off with football. Now we're
branching off across different sports.
So who we got in the pool hall today?
- Hey!
- Oh, we got the Jet on the runway.
- Yes, sir.
- Jason Terry, what's good with you, baby?
- Man, all is well!
- This is one of my favorite
episodes we about to do,
cuz this is talking about
my favorite team in the world:
the Dallas Mavericks, man.
And you've had some great memories on that team, man.
We gonna get into that. But I gotta see how nice you are on this table, man.
- Oh yeah,
oh yeah.
- Go ahead and break it, man.
- C’mon, man. I got a little bit of something.
Drop, ball!
- Going into 2011,
what was the confidence level that you had?
And what was the confidence level the team had?
- You already know, though.
The ultimate, ultimate, ultimate prediction, right?
Not the week before the game, or the day of the game.
Like, this is in preseason.
In training camp, we're at DeShawn Stevenson's house.
We're having some team bonding.
And we walk in, man, and he's like,
"Man, I got a tattoo artist. Man, he gonna come through.
You know, y'all get whatever you want. It's on me."
Like, "Oh, OK. Cool."
Me, I'm a man of many tattoos. All of 'em have meaning.
But this time I was like, "Man, I'm about to do something."
And so I get the Larry O'Brien Trophy tatted on my bicep,
but I didn't reveal it that night.
Wrapped it up, went home.
Then at shootaround the next day, we're in Orlando,
Coach Carlisle, "Bring it in, everybody. OK, let's get ready to roll tonight."
I'm like, "Hold up, fellas. I got something for you."
And I unwrapped it.
Boom.
And then I flexed,
but it was like crickets. Like, everybody was looking around like—
- [Laughing]
- What?
And Dirk just bust out,
"This guy is crazy.
- [Laughing]
He's a circus. Look at this guy."
I'm like, "Nah, man, I'm serious. I think we got the team that's gonna do it."
And then we went on our journey.
Uh oh.
Got a pool shark in the building.
- [Laughing]
I know, I know what time it is now.
- Game 6, I was an ESPN Dallas intern
watching the fanwatch that was going on in American Airlines Center
while y'all was in Miami.
Seconds count down. You see Dirk hopping off the floor.
Every team is doing this now, where you see them going to Vegas, going to
a big club after they win a championship to celebrate.
Y'all was the first ones really keeping this thing lit on social media.
I was geeked. I didn't know what to do. I couldn't go to sleep,
and I was 20, so I couldn't go out to bars.
You know, I didn't have a fake ID.
- That was the biggest celebration ever in the history because you did it in their city.
The owner is with you striking up the band, like, you don't see that.
You don't see owners, like, really just out there.
But to walk through their prestigious Club LIV, with the trophy, one,
and then this big ass wheelbarrow of ice.
To this day I haven't seen a bottle of Champagne that big.
And it was probably at least three-quarters of this pool table.
- Reportedly, that tab was 110,000 dollars.
- Wow.
- What do you remember from that night, man?
Cuz I'm mad I wasn't there.
- Man, I remember Lil Wayne
definitely gave us a shoutout on the mic.
I remember Cuban get on the stage with the mic.
Dirk was on stage with the mic.
After that, it's a blur.
- Let's get a shot in real quick.
- Yup.
- You’re there for another year with the Mavs.
- Try to do this repeat.
Doesn't work out.
From there you go to Boston.
- Mmhmm.
- Same level of confidence?
- Aw, man.
Now I'm an NBA champion.
- [Laughing]
I'm about to go join some other champions.
Growing up it was Celtics-Lakers. That was the rivalry. You watched it. Like,
that was our social media.
You wanted to see what those two were gonna do.
Now I get to join that franchise,
and for me it's like, man.
We got a real shot.
Miami was still running things in the East.
- 100 percent.
- I was there one year, but I will tell you this.
Boston got some of the greatest sports fans ever,
and every time I go back, it's all love.
- For real?
- Like, you would think I won a championship and played there, like, my whole career.
- You think it's off the strength of that tattoo? What do you think it's from?
- It couldn't have been how awful how LeBron did me.
- [Laughing]
Right?
- And how he, how he meme-ified me.
- Talk to me. What do you remember about that play?
What do you remember about that moment?
- I wanna say it's one of the lowest moments in my career, but at the same time,
I mean, I'll forever go down in history.
Like, you got dunked on by The King.
- [Laughing]
- Every camp, every clinic around America I go and talk to kids,
they don't ask, like,
"Man, how did it feel to play 19 years? How did it feel to play with Dirk or win a—"
- Win a championship, yeah.
What question they ask?
- How did it feel for LeBron to dunk on you like that?
- Like, c’mon man. Get outta here.
- What was it, a fast break?
- Yup. It was a fast break. But what happened was, I was coming down.
I turned the ball over.
- OK.
- So it's just instinct for me when you turn it over, “I got to get it back.”
So I'm chasing it. I mean, I might've chased their whole team and the coach
trying to get the ball back.
I got Chalmers coming at me, and then LeBron's coming down the middle.
I took my eye off of LeBron for one second,
chased Chalmers,
turned back around, and he was already in the air, like—
- [Laughing]
- in slow motion,
and what made me jump is what I'm trying to figure out.
- [Laughing]
- Like, there's no reason—
like, even if you did jump—
- You not gonna touch that, man.
- You ain't touching that.
No.
And I jumped, man.
He lifted me on his knee,
and I was still going up with him.
Like, LeBron just bang, bang, it was over.
Like, I elevated. I was in the rim.
- [Laughing]
And hit the ground, man.
I didn't hop up quick. I laid there for a minute.
And I think that's the picture, the meme, that's out.
Like, I'm laying there with my arms folded.
- [Laughing]
- Like being in a funeral, man.
- I can't front, bro. I was one of those people on
social media just dying laughing at this moment.
- For three weeks, I was checking my phone
and people were sending me messages like, “Man, you OK?”
Like, numbers I haven't heard in, in eight years,
I'm seeing numbers pop up. “Jet, are you good?”
“You dead, big homie? You good?”
I'm like, “I don't know what these people talking about.”
They even said on Wikipedia, they said
that was my death date.
It had the date and everything on there.
That's crazy, man.
- The internet don't give a damn about nobody, bro.
It is undefeated.
- Undefeated.
- What was the response from your teammates?
- Oh, they was killing me in the locker room,
destroying me.
Jokes and jokes and jokes.
I'm telling you, it kept up for a while.
All right.
- Jason Terry, you got 60 seconds.
See how many shots you can get in, but also let’s see
how many questions you can answer. You ready?
- Man, this is what I do.
- All right, let’s get it, man. Let’s start this thing off right.
In three, two, one, let’s get it!
- More fun playing with, Dirk or KG?
- KG.
- Jet, do you prefer private jets or commercial, man?
- Private.
- Celtics or Mavs? Don’t let me down!
- C’mon, Mavs.
- Let’s go, baby!
Luka or Giannis?
- Like Drake said, both.
- [Laughing]
Biggest memory of the Warriors Mav series?
- Man, when Dirk threw the chair and put a hole in the stadium.
Best three-point shooter in NBA history?
- Steph Curry.
- Best trash-talker you’ve ever played with?
- Kevin Garnett.
- Who did more for the headband, you or LeBron?
- Oh, yours truly.
- Who's the real Jet, you or Kenny Smith?
- The Jet by name, and not by game.
- I’m sorry, Kenny Smith.
Best city you’ve ever visited on the road?
- Seattle.
- Seattle!
- All-Star Weekend or Super Bowl Weekend?
- All-Star.
- MJ or LeBron?
- MJ!
- Funniest teammate you’ve ever had?
- Greg Buckner.
- Loudest locker room guy you’ve ever played with?
- Corey Brewer.
- Eight seconds! Pregame snack routine that you've ever had?
- Chicken fingers.
- Who are you listening to before a game, man?
- Man, Nipsey Hussle the great.
- And that’s time right there. 28 scores.
We gonna end this on “The Marathon Continues.”
Jet—
- Man, appreciate you.
- appreciate you pulling up to the pool hall with us, man.
- Love.
- Subscribe to Bleacher Report for
more Untold Stories.